people making some very creative ships
in Starfield I already made a video
covering like Recreations of other ships
from popular culture but here's for some
really creative ones this one is the BLT
this is from Reddit user bullet theory
N7 and the the bacon is what's getting
me this I don't think is a reference to
anything unless it's something I don't
know of it's obviously a little star
warsy just a really really clean
ship design like how nice does this look
the Reddit post from yep owl does
it took them hours here we have just one
very big transporter Dear God
this is just like cargo containers on
cargo containers on cargo containers hey
you'll never be over incumbent ever
again this is from professional
underscore job 1154 on Reddit this is
cool as hell
sp7r here made a scorpion dude
that looks so sick I wonder how
functional it is oh my gosh I love it
how awesome is that